well some y'all ready jump me welcome
back to your favorite podcast gentlemen
welcome back once again back in Riften
studios you doing it live I'm doing it
fun doing it just for you keeping it
going and I got a special YouTube only
episode right now now my good buddy mr.
Andrew Santino right now so I hope you
enjoy
alright y'all like I said I got a
special YouTube on the episode this is a
bonus episode this week just for YouTube
now the sound is gonna be a little wonky
I was still working out all the tech
tech with this and so it was a little
bit it's been difficult on my one-man
show so please I know the sound is wonky
it's echoing in some parts it fixes in
some areas but just try to enjoy don't
worry I'll have him back on again and
we'll do it right but for now here is my
good friend mr. ed your Santino okay
what's up everybody thanks again for
watching this is another skyping with
Griffin and this is my good old buddy
mr. Andrew Santino Skype
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I got a grip I don't need to show
it off like you I don't give you those
jr. those ginger good looks so you don't
wanna you could make an 80s sitcom with
that song it's the start of the sitcom
wait let me see move your head to the
left real quick let me see that chair is
that one of those nerdy game or chair
yeah of course it is yeah it's an elite
this is an elite max II 12700 II win
gaming actually who's a sponsor well I
mean you do what do you mean you play
video games that crazy yeah but I'm
still cheap like don't act like so to me
I need to know how you how you holding
up let your thoughts how's everything I
mean a lady has been eating eat eating
in every day he's been the worst really
I hate Weiser I dude I want to go out to
dinner I don't like cooking meals every
day like I I would probably say
breakfast and coffee
I would have at home most days but then
a lot then two days a week or whatever I
would go have a breakfast meeting with
somebody or go see a friend for
breakfast and get coffee I miss a [ __ ] a
lot and then and then lunch almost never
I never ate lunch and I don't think I've
eaten lunch at home and over a decade
dude and that's dinner depends on if I
would say how many shows I had if I had
an early show and all that stuff but now
dude it's just like breakfast lunch and
dinner at home but I would work it out
as much as I can I've been running
almost every day cuz you know I like
running I've been running a ton again
but it's just like I usually like
running because it gets me excited to do
shows at night or like to have something
going and like if I go to work out an
afternoon I'm like excited because then
I'm like oh tonight I got to shows like
you know and then you think about people
that you're gonna see there and maybe
see afterwards I see you at the store
you know I mean it's like to not have
that excitement to just like her and I
just sit and watching TV shows and
movies are like playing a game or
something it's just you feel so like I
don't know it's just I'm look it's it's
it's champagne problems it's great but
it's just like it's just a bummer like I
wish we could just go out and do
anything I would love to go you know get
a drink somewhere or go like I don't
know go to somebody's house it would be
something so nice to just go see
somebody and then I find it like I find
it like it's very challenging like I
find a challenging to relationship to
it's like I realize it I don't spend 24
hours a day with one person you know I
mean it's like because you both were
working so much yes that's what I'm
saying so you realize that you have to
fill that time with like or you don't
realize how important it is to be away
from someone that when you curl you come
back with like a new new energy and like
oh this is what happened today
you just need other experiences and I
think being a comic we're kind of crazy
we need that it was a comedy like and
and podcasting and all this stuff has
taken some a weird break because you
can't there's no life to report on the
podcast do you know what I mean oh yes
for sure what we're all talking about a
tiger King in the same [ __ ] as we're
all doing
like no one has any other experiences
there's nothing else going on you you
know like you run out of stuff to do and
you run out of stuff to talk about cuz
your life is like not happening right
now and most of your material and your
life comes to the surface from doing
stuff and it kind of feeding itself into
the comedy world too so it's like no
one's gonna see in movies I know how
much you love movies I've nobody seen
movies no one see movies
no one's going out to like any sort of
common area places where we would get
that social interaction that builds
material and builds you know kind of
like that that the remnants of the day
that start to piece together for us in
order to write jokes is now you go
online and I'm not not talking [ __ ] but
like we're talking all right every comic
is writing Cova jokes I mean every all
of us yeah
and it's like it's all boring now like
now Twitter is like another either
stupid Cova joke which I've done you've
done we all do and then and then some
political [ __ ] it's like before you
would get some other fun random stuff
thrown in there but there's no life to
have on there so I don't know man it's
just it's been a little challenging you
know no dude I'm with you 100% gonna be
like don't you hate when you iron your
clothes at home my jokes gonna be about
like putting whites and solids in the
washing machine wrong and [ __ ] like that
not filling up the Brita and stuff like
that it's not as crazy I need that's why
I was like I'm doing this cuz I'm like I
need an outlet I need that like I need
to call people that I should talk [ __ ]
with it just like connect with you know
what you ever had anybody over at the
house no I haven't no nobody no just
Rachel no I haven't had anybody over to
come over because I just don't I don't
know like why biscuit she's been out in
public
yeah I know I know but she's not for
right now she's actually off work for
like a week like a lot of places gay
people to climb off are they asking this
this there is their choice
you know but like I know but then she
has to go back in a week they're
probably see I'm saying she goes back
out then what you have to do if to spray
her before she comes in yeah i dipper in
tar
at first like rubber do cuz you hear
like all these people like Michael yo he
was really sick there's that other comic
I saw on Instagram Sammy he was really
sick he says covert Sam I don't forgot
his last name sandy something just one
of these comics I follow you know but
they had Kovac yeah Michael Joe was like
he had it he was really sick you know he
really did have it yeah he said he was
gonna rumor about it but I didn't want
to spread it around cuz I don't know if
that was well I you know where I heard
it Joe Rogan podcast so you know what
did Joe say it to Joe was talking to
somebody he was talking to oh he forgot
her Burt when he had Burt on my phone
looking up Michael yo Instagram post
about it I don't know if he did or not
cuz he said he was gonna die I talked to
him I hit him up I texted him I was like
yo man how you doing everything good
he's like taking a day by day that kind
of thing so Jesus he was like that yeah
man and in the way and Mamie gave me
pause because of how even how Joe was
talking about it cuz Joe is saying like
look Michael Hill is a healthy looking
dude it's not like he's like you know
he's not a fat guys and Shay I mean it's
just a weird virus you know so weird how
it affects people you know some people
like they get over it like it's like a
really bad cold or some people they
can't breathe they feel like they're
drowning they got to go to the hospital
get on a ventilator
and I some people we have a family
friend you loser
one of the symptoms can be you lose your
sense of taste and smell yes there's an
that's what he had there's a guy yeah a
couple of headaches and he lost his
sense of taste and smell and that's it
there was a guy I know but that but I'm
saying is like but that's what makes it
weird I mean it depends on the person
because like I say Michael yo he thought
he was gonna die and then like someone
else like you say tasted smell there was
a guy that hit me up on Instagram just a
fan you know and he was like hey thanks
for your podcast I'm recovering from
Corona and I was like I said I wish I'm
gonna call him up too and be like tell
me about your experience because I just
like hearing like what people have gone
through
cuz it's different for everybody I'm
just worried about my parents how the
parents do it yeah good I mean they're
bare hunkered down hard though like they
haven't left the house in two weeks
oh I'll be you know they're just stuck
in their house like I'm not really
worried about them because they're so
antisocial oh but all their friends are
so like healthy I guess you should say
for their age which I know isn't the
determining factor but it really isn't
no I know but but but but if you're
older and unhealthy it's way worse
that's just way worse for the flu dude
older people who are unhealthy they get
the flu can die you know what I mean so
like when you get older when you're past
65 70 all that you're healthy you're a
Bobby's age you know I'm not really
worried about them to be honest because
they seem to be taking it very serious I
think a lot of people of that generation
maybe aren't but they seem to be taking
it legit serious like they you know I
told them about spraying their mail do
you spray your mail I [ __ ] lifestyle
every pack that comes did you did we do
a shows two weeks ago were you out of
town
you know when like Bobby was in like
Florida I was it was in denver denver
denver where he was in chicago and
Friday
whatever the show got canceled that was
my birthday that's right know my
birthday was March 12th so I had come so
I called you a before I third Friday the
13th is when my show got canceled no I
did a Friday night show I did two shows
on Friday and then Bobby calls me and
Bobby's like he's leaving Denver he's
not gonna do with Saturday shows he
already cancelled and I was still did my
Saturday shows you did yeah I did this
Avenue shows you know it was I was
already there you know I was like it
wasn't really like spooky yet you know
well that's what I said you know like my
show was on Friday the 13th
the governor said that morning or the
mayor said that morning sorry that
Chicago had anybody over crowds of to
fifth
they highly advised against it and then
Live Nation called me and was like I'm
with my agent and was like you know like
do you want to do the show it's like
first of all I was like there's like 600
700 people okay that's more than double
the limit Wow and I was like I don't
think that's a good idea I mean you know
like I felt terrible so I put a post up
on Instagram being like hey I'm sorry
but like I don't want to be the guy
who's responsible for people getting
sick yes a bad look you know to me but
they put it on you know maybe mad that
they put it on our shoulders it's like
just just cancel the venue's so I don't
have to make the decisions look I didn't
like that there was comedy clubs that I
heard that we're like - asking the
performers it was like oh whatever you
want to do it's like no dude tell them
not to so then you save all this face in
the future so no one is put in a jiffy
in a jeopardy like did you see um
someone was performing a rapper was
performing that night mm-hmm
maybe post Malone or somebody whatever
they got so much heat online people
being like this is so irresponsible like
this
it's like broke he didn't know the venue
said yes like so back then a month ago
you know more than a month ago today now
it was everyone was still kind of you
know whatever about it no one really you
know this was this was this was March
13th and that happened like just around
that time so what are we talking three
four weeks now it's like no man you know
I so anyway but what are you gonna do
you know at my told tour go reschedule I
haven't slept in this late I haven't
slept in this late since maybe college
like like I've been sleeping in every
day cuz I have I wake up and I'm like
why there's no schedule today I know
it's crazy it's great like I'm like I'm
like I think for like to make it a
little more light like like I'm watching
ozarks on Netflix right now oh my god
dude dude oh you started that's not even
a spoiler because like all I'm saying is
when the young do with the hair what he
did May
I know what but you know what I think
Mex leaks is making a mistake with they
should be releasing those shows once a
week you know to me well here but here's
why I agree with you but here's why
here's the only reason why I would say
no Tiger King became an international
phenomenon like that because you could
see all the episodes check it out dude
it's so you could get distracted with
others I know but it still would have
happened
just like Game of Thrones still with a
healthy Thrones is different no is
you're not different I'm saying look let
me finish my point in a in a month cuz
we're still gonna be inside I don't care
what they say if that's there until they
have a vaccine this [ __ ] is still gonna
sprint you know yeah so we gonna then
we're gonna be done with all the shelves
I know look imagine if you were still
like oh man I'm gonna episode two of
Tiger Tiger King what do you think of it
you know I just think that because
they're not gonna have any new content
they're not making they're not feeling
stuff on the less things on the [ __ ] on
the sly
you know Netflix Netflix probably has 19
comedy specials lined up for the month
of March yeah there's already too many
of them come out Segura and delay out in
this right in one chunk I don't know who
else is next I'm sure they got a bunch
of people lined up I tell you who it's
not I'll tell you is not on there your
ass in my ass yeah I know dude and
that's something else it's like that
applix gonna be like come on man can I
can a brother get something out during
the corona Spike Lee minutes I'm gonna
do a zoom special words like I'll have
like 300 phase on my screen you know
just like that to each other it'll be
that great but we can't each other not
laughing that the other person they went
to the wall on camera and I'm just like
yeah we tell the joke and I'll be like
this ya know like I told Bob - it's hard
to be funny right now it's hard to be
funny I don't know like I just not like
I'm like my funny bone is gone but it's
like you know I'm just a little
like I need more experience to feel
alive again you know like this the
trappings of this have hurt my mental
you know like my physical I've been
trying to like stay active and take
walked what the dog take runs workout
and do all that stuff so I like stay
physically active but my mental my brain
is rotted I mean it's just like there's
no engagement even if I've tried to like
read or like really get into something I
can turn on my brain it's just I just
you know it just feels like I'm spinning
the wheel for no reason you know
have you written jokes no I'm not I'm
not trying because the only thing that's
on my mind is like you know these things
it's like how the virus and Trump and
like you know the things people are
saying I'm just like no no thank you
if anything if any material I'm gonna
write is gonna be about like
relationships because this [ __ ] is
challenging as a [ __ ] you know
yeah but I'm already pet but what I'm
saying is I'm already past the bad part
you know like it was like the first few
days of like 24 hours it was like and
then now it's like we're in a good place
and so you know this money rachel said
to me like all her girlfriends are
taxing each other they [ __ ] love this
they love 24 hours a day your man is
right there Netflix and chill every
night they know where you are 24 hours a
day I've been doing all the cooking bro
I'm good like this morning I made her
breakfast you know I mean I grounded
some coffee I'm doing all this [ __ ] I'm
doing [ __ ] I've never done before
because I was like I'm bored I'm gonna
keep myself busy and I'm learning
hobbies and [ __ ] so I mean I'm trying to
find the bright side of what's going on
right now but it's a lot bro you been
married a while so I was challenging we
had breakfast and coffee every day
because we just gets like made when the
dog is up and like that's a hard one
usually before she dips but it's funny
because lunch has been such a challenge
we don't every lunch together she she
eats lunch during work I eat lunch
always out I'm always gone in middle the
day they're like coming and going from
somewhere and so now eating lunch at
home feels like a force like I have to
do it and I don't even
do it you know even like I'm some times
I won't even be that hungry but I'm like
I should be eating something it's the
middle of the day I'm gonna feel worse
later but like you know lunch is always
my favorite thing to eat like out when
I'm out with friends lunch is not fun at
home lunch is not fun of her I have you
know we have it we haven't we haven't um
we haven't ordered out that much which i
think is crazy like oh I'm trying to
save money
I'm just like all the CIB know I'm
always a frugal [ __ ]
oh so I'm playing you know what I don't
want to be that guy that's like I told
you I told you that's not the part
that's my coming anytime you wanna spend
all your money do that is you just not
money you're like now I'm holding out of
this me me I have a couple of luxury
expenses but other than that everything
goes everything's a debate you know
you're thinking about your Ferrari or no
six storey house you have in a bunker in
a panic room who are you talking to you
think this is Chris D'Elia what that
dude has three houses bigger than my one
house I know he's got a dungeon I feel I
know that we personally have a bunch of
friends who they make good money doing
stand-up right but they still live in
gig to Gig you know you know we got a
lot you know yeah your friends living
beyond a means you know to $1200 car
payment you know $5,000 grant that kind
of shaky like good weekend but it's like
but do you got a grand a weekend ready
for you know seven weeks in the bank you
know you know the fan so it's like it's
and I'm just saying that this is like
the first world problems for but it's
not because it equalized everybody so
there are people who only
a thousand dollars a month and that [ __ ]
it's corn you know I mean and so it's
like it's a it's like so I just I hope
we can get we get past I hope you
recover I think we will we've survived
worst you know we've survived worse in
this country but Dan this is gonna be
difficult because like I said until we
get a vaccine we go be in the house I
know have you been donating to anybody
hunger if you've been you've been
spreading around that money love I've
helped people I'm sure you Chicago
families calling you late
hey mister mr. Hollywood mr. Hollywood
I've given away some I've helped I've
helped out in different ways actually
some I'm actually a little bit proud of
that I've a different ways yeah that's
that's cold Frank you know but I have I
first of all I've retweeted that laughs
factory [ __ ] to get the server some
money and I don't me too
well I die I donated because I felt I
felt like you know those people are the
ones that get clipped the hardest like a
server you know they're not making
enough money to survive something like
this it's already a second job I know
that's exactly well that's my that's my
point is I get worried you know cuz I
know friends that are in that position
where they work you know a couple gigs
but those gigs all got taken away from
them I'm here in a few I tweeted out
that tweeted but I texted a lot of my
close friends that you know they had
that thing about rent in California is
you're gonna they're gonna give you a
break for two months so I've been to
send messages about that but like even
then I don't know if that's really gonna
help and I'm hearing some historic
comedy clubs might be closing down
because they can't pay their lease like
I heard some rumors about a DC improv
you know that I don't know if they can
continue I don't necessarily connect
place but we don't know people this is
what I'm trying to say is we don't know
people's situation like we don't know
their finances we don't know their
finances we don't know if like the money
coming in from the club is going
you know you know upgrade somebody's
house and they said all the money's put
away or they got like a kid in private
school they got like expensive mortgage
be everybody this is like a ripple of
flight that everybody is dealing with
and not everybody understands yeah no
you're right yeah we I mean you don't
know well yeah actually you gonna find
out how many people are living beyond
their means that's that's I think the
triggers you'll see people that live
really well and when they're struggling
you're like well it's because you've
been spending so much money yeah living
wait wait this is this is the this is a
calling card for everyone to live at or
below their means you should be at or
below your means like when you live
beyond your means man because you want
to flash and you want to have the car or
drive the thing or do you have the crib
or buy the clothes and have all the [ __ ]
it's like good luck man when the [ __ ]
hits the fan like I've never been that
way I don't ever spend money I don't
have
dude I and I'm lucky I will say I'm
lucky I've never been in credit card
debt I know a lot of my friends have
I've never had it but it's also because
I've never bought anything extravagant
ever I live dime to dime when I moved to
LA and then as I got more I luckily just
acquired small snippets of things as
time went on but I never you know I
dude I never stunted when I got my first
check I mean I drove a Hyundai for
forever entry-level Sonata when I didn't
have to but like you know what like you
don't get that you like we were like
we're never like we always feel like
this is gonna be it you know what I mean
like like I'm not gonna survive this
well comics I was after every job I go
this is it that's it never home oh yeah
I mean we don't most comics I know live
below or at there means not above it
because they know that this is fleeting
this isn't like comedian comedians
getting like a little bit of attention
or fame or or even in the in the actor
world or whatever like that that thing
is a come and go thing you know so like
if you're if you think you're like
they're never gonna not give me work
it's like you're [ __ ] out of your
mind
they could I don't care who you are
they're quick to find the next you and
so I guess most comics I know they pinch
pennies hard and they're smart about
their money because they know
it can go and like when people talk
about like people online are like well
you guys don't know what it's like to
you know I lost an hourly wage it's like
my man we don't get paid unless we work
like we're the same way like there's
benefits there's nothing there's this
weird misnomer it's like dude we don't
have I don't have [ __ ] dental through
stand-up comedy I don't have medical you
know I mean like we don't have a 401k
that gives us half of like we're in the
same position as people that are hourly
workers it just depends on how much
money you make as a comic and how you
save it and how you organize your
finances but like I don't like when
people are like oh you know what who's
calm who's complaining about it's like -
if if we don't if we don't if you don't
move your feet then we don't eat right
outcast it's like if we don't perform if
we don't perform we don't get a check
you know like in Chicago I sold that I
sold that show and I and sadly couldn't
do the show so now they either
reschedule it and people can come on
July 25th or they have to give them
their money back if those people need
their money so like guess what a lot of
these [ __ ] people need their money
and it's the same for me it's like well
if I don't get up there on the mic I
don't get a check we don't just get
checks in the mail
for not performing so I ask all my fans
of the podcast I go please watch all the
ads playing in the background beginning
that's not a crazy request like why not
all you do for me is just watch all my
ads please yeah that's real money but
who knows how long even that'll last
because if nobody has money to buy the
products that YouTube is advertising
then what you know tell you something
Amazon is seeing a such a surge because
they become like the place that people
people are getting everything delivered
through and I think people are buying a
lot of [ __ ] because they're at home and
they want to stay occupied not anything
extravagant but like people are buying a
lot of workout equipment people are
buying a lot of like video game stuff
people like anything that's like your
hobby it's a it's it's tenfold right
like if you like working out I bet you
people are ordering workout equipment if
you love playing video games I guarantee
you people are buying it on a video game
[ __ ] like
I want to buy some pottery I want to get
a pottery wheel and start like like an
ghosts or whatever wheel
I'm already big oversize so we could
just you know here's no here's what I
know you'll turn full white on me is
when you start making bread if you start
making [ __ ] bread I know you're full
white that's every have you not yet but
I'm just funny you say that cuz I was
looking into like I want to start baking
dope-ass meals white girl online is
making Fred and guess what you're my
favorite white girlfriend you're the
whitest girlfriend I am right online I'm
gonna lose my [ __ ] if you make bread
online it you'll be just like every
basic Becky online will hold up but it's
gonna be cinnamon raisin so stop hey I'm
not doing but I'm not doing [ __ ]
white bread no my buddy made Nutella
banana bread and I was like bro can I
please have some of that [ __ ] and he was
like sorry man I went right in the belly
he's like the moment we made it we ate
it I was like I don't have any skills
like that I can look like grill but
baking is like no bro I don't bake okay
let me tell you this little tip I got
one of these like food services man like
blue apron sunbath oh those are great
because they give you everything you
need and they really they get you into a
pattern of like oh this is actually I
can make a meal in 20 minutes it is
actually great so I'm in and it's
actually low cost cuz I'm just trying to
get things that's low cost you know what
I mean you know but baking is not cheap
baking stuff you have to get all the
materials you get you know I mean that's
not cheap to do well I mean I'm gonna be
baking like cakes but people just people
bake extravagant [ __ ] and it just takes
forever and I'm like no way man I ain't
doing that what are you doing not that I
don't know whatever the [ __ ] I'm doing
either Bobby though to do the podcast
that's been a whole thing man we're we
did one I don't know if we're gonna do
another due to what's going on like I I
feel like it's a low risk thing if it's
wrong
- God you know what I mean it's like you
have my office space is that what that
is yeah it's in a studio so it's not
like you just gotta clean up and stuff
and you just kind of like no we created
a thousand times but also yeah I don't
know man I want to keep doing them
because it's it's like helps me stay
sane but and I think the risk is
unbelievably low and it's just two dudes
and a thing and we don't sit anywhere
near each other you know I mean we don't
touch so like by the way though you have
if you if you look here on the screen
here you know I don't know what all this
[ __ ] you guys have that's a that's
our fake brick wall like you that's what
I so dope began you'll see in the new
one - we put up some new we got
something new but the joke was that our
set was garbage people made fun of it so
we were like okay yeah it's I mean but
obviously I said it was good I've been
saying like you guys did all this so I
can't green-screen into your podcast
anymore so right and I did this I didn't
appreciate this episode [ __ ] Bobby I
don't I don't know if you're gonna be
able to hear and I hope I don't get in
trouble but this is Bobby time to say
something that's gonna get me in so I
had a conversation with our dear friend
Eric Griffin I'm not even gonna continue
this [ __ ] you're gonna get some views
man you guys you know you guys are no
you know what it's a nightmare on
purpose we thought it was kind of funny
so we made it even orge is the one that
was like George George reads all the
comments and he's like I'm gonna say I
need to redecorate it and I was like
okay and I was like here's some money
then go to Target and he bought a bunch
of stuff it
I said go go somewhere and get stuff and
he said I'm gonna go to Target I said
fine and he got all that hacky stuff
from Target and I thought I was
hilarious like it
the one time I'd be giving my thirty one
dollars is that he's got a credit card
no friends expense account right there
that's all George
and people are like we're Bobby and you
doin man psyche dude also we don't I
don't give a [ __ ] about the set that's
like the funniest thing that people
complain of
it's like you think I [ __ ] care about
the set the set is the last thing I care
about on this show I care about Bobby
showing up on time and us doing it that
must be a nightmare tell me about that
oh my well I mean here's the deal bob
has been super responsive because of
what's going on so cuz when this whole
thing started we had like really set a
schedule and now that we were because we
were on the road it was like we have to
be diligent and so we were and it was
pretty great and then now that this is
going on you know Kyle has been a little
overprotective and is scared of him
leaving the house in general because
he's I like I get it I get leaving the
house is a scary thing but like this is
extremely insular it's us it's sprayed
down it's it's clean it's like it's
about us it's to me in my opinion it's
safer than going the [ __ ] grocery
store which is a nightmare like people I
don't I went the other day that's a
nightmare
it's a it is a [ __ ] there's so many
people there you don't know these people
who's sick you know at least with Bob
and I we know our circles and I know
what he's doing I know he's not leaving
the house so it's like well I don't know
why he is he's doing this kind of stuff
like that doesn't yeah but I think but I
think I think I'm more scared to go to
[ __ ] Trader Joe's he's nasty I don't
know these other people you don't know
where they're coming and going from they
could be they could be not obeying the
rules they could be going hanging out
with people and [ __ ] now like people
that have to work I feel the worst for
like the UPS guy the FedEx cat the
Amazon Prime dude like he's on overtime
and you know I was talking to Gary Owen
and Gary was telling me how he's really
a hypochondriac so he was like you know
the corona virus can live on cardboard
for three days it's that kind of stuff
you know what I mean yeah something I
spray my I spray my Amazon packages with
Lysol I'm not getting yeah I feel you I
totally I do it cuz I think it's worth
it to spray that [ __ ] cuz it could be
one of them hundreds of people that
handled it you know yeah man I I went to
the store and they were they were
practicing like the six-feet thing like
outside
distorted a won't he let a certain
number of people in but I was just
talking about this on another episode
that like there was this girl she just
[ __ ] sneezed out loud that you know
just know like no regard and I'm like yo
sneezy Magoo like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you might have and they have a
look on your face like I just did
something wrong like give me a little
bit of like oh I'm sorry I know this is
scary yeah that's why we need guns we
can't get rid of guns Oh bang gone yeah
no you just in court like the [ __ ]
needs Your Honor I feel that I feel that
next case
yep when you know when I was taking that
flight home from Chicago after the show
got canceled I stayed with family for a
minute and I took the flight home and on
the flight was um you know like a half
the plane was full yeah my mind up and
and people were still like coughing and
doing what you normally hear on an
airplane you know and it just tripped me
out so much that I was like I'm in a I'm
in a petri dish in the sky and then I
went online and I was like what's the
transmittable you know numbers from
airplanes apparently this is wild they
like the FAA regulations on HEPA filters
are crazy they have to be so like it has
to be masseur callate so much more than
your average like coffee shop or
restaurant or whatever and in regular
space so I felt safer after I read that
that I was like oh the airplane might
not be that bad unless you know you're
touching a surface and rubbing your
eyeballs or whatever but like if it's
[ __ ] were on the plane like you
know I was gonna get I was gonna die
from the from the cleaning fumes
you know me yeah like everybody I had
Clorox robson wipes and we're like
wiping everything down and the opposite
there's people that are out there that
don't believe in this [ __ ] I think that
this is like a hoax or some [ __ ] yes
they're just one comedian who was
tweeting about that alike this is like
the liberal agenda socialist country or
I don't know I forgot the guy's name I
just saw the tweet and I was like I
can't I can't be involved with this
because it just doesn't make any sense
like you know
like what like you know this is all
gonna change when somebody that dies
that they know you know like it's just
like you know I saw this Trump yesterday
and he was like you know I just want to
have governor's to be grateful he was
talking like that and I was like
somebody he knows has to really get sick
that he's gonna be like oh oh you know
what this [ __ ] is serious all right
let's get these ventilators out let's do
all the things I need to do I just think
that it's not touching people apparently
for them to feel like you know hey let
me stop talking like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what I mean but it is but it is
touching people but the problem is the
media gives it like a quarter of a day
attention you know like a young kid died
this morning I read a 19 year old girl
who's had no health conditions you know
twenty two old college athlete you know
like like it gets a little of attention
and it gets pushed under the rug and
like I don't know who tweeted it but
somebody was like how come we can't know
what the pre-existing conditions were of
the humans that died because that should
be the most important and I put like
she's out there like this your mom your
mom is older now does she have any
conditions
no no thankfully it's other than
dementia so she thinks you know she
wants to go out everyday she wants to
you know go to her dead grandmother's
house everyday you know so that's a yes
to keep getting reminded that what's
going on yeah but they got the new she's
got mild dementia so she knows but she
keeps hitting me everyday it's like
Groundhog Day you know so she's like oh
no we can't go out I'm bored I've been
in the house I'm hope my grandmother's
okay that kind of thing you know and her
grandma yes my mother's grandmother
would still be alive she came overhead
what would you do what would you do what
if you just told her that she is alive I
do do that I told her I said ma your
grandmother you can't be near her she's
too old she's at an age that's really
she gonna get sick you know because not
be I'm not making a joke I just think
like sometimes I might be even easier to
be yeah what you're supposed to do you
have dementia you don't you just know
logic do you do they don't understand
logic they don't understand anything so
I just got to keep going I heart I went
I went and saw her she's fine don't
worry oh you do yes oh yeah like lie at
some point
that's so how about mom but now my mom
wants to get her a phone she said I
gotta get her a phone so I'm like II I
might make a Google Voice number and
give it to my mom and then when that
number of rings I'm an answer of all
[ __ ] people that could pull it off to
you basically you're basically one of
the clumps you know so transform and
that you can transform it and of that
grandmother no but you know I think it's
um
that's wild for your mother to be going
through something like this but not
really no yeah she doesn't know but she
doesn't get it you know it's it's like
you know it's hard is that's the hard
that's the hardest part like it's like
it really hit me cuz I guess I was in my
birthday was March 12th and I was in
Tennessee so I called my mom and I was
like hey mom you know so you know
today's my birthday you know and she was
like oh yeah and there's usually let me
sing him happy birthday but it was like
a moment that I was like how [ __ ] cuz
this is something she always would
remember you know just yes you know I
mean it's a thing that she would I made
a big deal out of and so it like really
hit me hard where I was like cuz I've
been dealing with it you know I've been
talking about it on stage I've been
dealing with in my own way but that was
the one of the first times that it
really hit me hard
oh wow yeah you know and the crazy part
is like she still but she'll still say
how's Rachael you know I'm like like
she's dead
my dis [ __ ] don't know my birthday but
[Laughter]
she asking about her this is like so
it's like it's weird the things that she
remembers so well it's whatever gets
like some things get searched into your
brain she and she liked Rachel and she
didn't want to remember the day you were
born that was just like some things are
more important you know pain [ __ ] I'm
gonna forget about that [ __ ] it's funny
that there's no selectiveness to it
conscious there's no conscious selecting
that's right not just selective so like
she doesn't know
when things are more prominent which is
even more interesting to find out like
why the brain lines up certain things to
stick and other things to be gone my
grandmother is you know she's kind of
like let go in a weird way that's been
terrible to like watch because my
grandfather died seven years ago seven
or eight years ago and like you know
she's been depleting since then but but
but this has been just the worst cuz she
got a bad disease something hit her hard
last year got you and and now she's now
she's like dude it's so weird to say
this cuz this breaks my heart but like
now she's become it's um well not mean
but she's she's so short that cuz I know
she's frustrated that it breaks your
heart cuz you're like well I know she's
mad she's just like mad at the world and
mad that she can't go you know I took
her for a walk and it broke my heart man
I took her for a walk and like dude I
used to go have a drink with my
grandmother at lunch somewhere we'd go
out to lunch
and go get a sandwich or a salad and we
would talk and we'd have a drink a
cocktail and I'd drive her home and we
you know I mean it was like she was she
was she was so alive and now I couldn't
walk her to the block and back and I
like shattered my heart man I couldn't
it really [ __ ] me up something awful
that because it was happening during
this [ __ ] right so like like you
with your mother it's like it's
happening during now like during all
this [ __ ] where I can't leave and like
these these emotions take over when
you're like why couldn't this [ __ ]
have happened any other time other than
when I can't leave my goddamn house you
know and say like I can't get on a plane
and go anywhere if I want to what
something even want to go to I don't
want to go to my parents his place where
they are I just don't want to go there
because I don't want to risk anything
because it was that place in Seattle
that was like you know elderly people
and it was like 20 it decimated that
place 27 30 people died the highest
concentration of deaths in the shortest
amount of time of the right
until unfortunate I and I'm not saying
this to be negative but until New York
cuz they said New York is liable to have
half the city's population will have it
they said in a month half yeah it's
because they're so on top of each other
I mean that's a while to think about
whether or not that comes to fruition
which I hope to god it doesn't I mean
not like that's the thing as I hope for
these people's sake yeah that it doesn't
happen like that but it's you know the
more you think about that the more
you're like well it's just going to keep
toppling people until we get whatever
the [ __ ] Tom Hanks got give us what Tom
got okay I heard they're back I just saw
read today that they're back we were
worried about that I would have been
Armageddon O'Connor it would've gotten
Tom Hanks well you think the toilet
paper would have been gone it just would
have been like it has been crazy we
needed that [ __ ] to survive just
so we could feel safe if he died I would
have bought a gun for real and started
looting and shooting like that's it
that's it I'm kidding I'm killing people
I'm going out strong I got to just do
what I need to do because tee-hanks is
dead it's like you know and all these
celebrities has gotten quite sick like
eat Rochelle but got really sick I think
right and I'm like oh my god i e we
already see you are you already look
like you ready this is this very scary
picture of you for that for some stupid
reason like I was just joking around
this is me at an indoor gun range and my
buddy bachelor party from a month ago
and people are like safe environment
yeah beyond safe dude so [ __ ] said
people are coming just some some people
hitting me up about like didn't think
you were this type of guy to support
guns it's like or are you talking about
dude I just went to a gun range to shoot
inside yeah I just just like people want
thank you I can't win for losing and the
more popular you are because you're like
you got it for instance you know you're
very popular now your podcast is popular
you're the one with Bobby is popular so
like you know you have more people so
them like it's like you know there's
just there's just so many hater trolls
out there or hated people out there
you know what we do is part of the game
whatever it's there that's on them to do
whatever they want to do I feel like
it's like dude like like like me and
come along for the ride or leave me
alone it's just like to just like come
along and have fun or leave us alone I
never understood that like wasting your
time talking [ __ ] in any SF it's like
all right man if that's that seems like
a real big waste of your life especially
because life is so notably precious
right now it's like why are you
occupying yourself with somebody else's
life but whatever man we're gonna keep
doing us that's why I think like this is
either gonna make people stronger as
comics or or your people are gonna bust
or just ask people to dynami just as a
comic just it's just a stronger person
or 42 yeah yes more to our community
because it's what we'll see it from our
friends to see who like comes back
stronger and changes perspective on life
and [ __ ] and you know but yeah
you're right as a society I hope it
makes us stronger I doubt it Jeff Bezos
should [ __ ] start donating start
donating Bezos [ __ ] the richest [ __ ]
on earth yeah he like you know the
stimulus package can come from him I set
up a thing that said 25 million dollars
and they were like proud of that I was
like 25 that's that's like me giving
away a hundred bucks yeah if one time
iliyan yeah the guy could give away a
billion dollars just to see work what's
it what's his letters like it was like
Chris Rock had that funny joke did like
he's so rich he got divorced and is
still the richest man in the world as of
2020 113 billion dollars a hundred
thirteen billion dollars my thing is
like is that just sitting in a bank
account is that it like I'll be of a
savings like you know a main checking
account like and say how much money like
it let you know what's funny though if
he had if you had a hundred billion
dollars in a checking account and you
were earning 2% on that you know yeah do
you know what that is you know what it
was like 20 million dollars you know to
reap a hundred and thirteen billion
dollars uh-huh
1% of that
1% is 1 billion 130 million that's 1%
right right
so if this dude 113 billion if he gave
away let me check this out though this
is all he have to do though man check
this out all he has to do is put money
in people's account
I just want Jeff Bezos to put a hundred
million dollars in my account okay let
me keep it for a year
yeah interest that I earn on that
account will be mine and I'll give him
back his 100 million he can do that I
think I you know you could get in a good
year you could get four to six percent
return you know the game so four million
dollars you mean to tell me he don't
even have to give me four million
dollars I'm just holding let me hold
something
Bezos let me just hold it let me hold it
for him oh did I pass it to my friends
so I go hey Andrew here's that honey
here's a hundred million from Bezos like
this in your account for a year and then
it just keeps going and going and going
and going and going yeah you know let me
hold it this is incredible if he gave
away one tenth of a percent one tenth of
one percent that's a hundred and
thirteen million dollars oh one tenth of
one percent if you gave away one tenth
of one tenth of a percent of your net
worth let's see let's because we know
everybody knows what Eric Griffin
network let's look up online what a lot
of it that's wrong I saw one I saw one
that was worth eight million dollars I
was like what where's this money my
financial guy hit me up he was like yo
Eric are you keeping something from me
I'm like don't believe that [ __ ] no I
like that people pretend like it is real
like it's like a [ __ ] of course this
is not real
Eric riffin Network family age married
wife a family height net worth then I
came up there's so many of these net
worth websites as they do and where
would they even okay here you go
where they got your birthday March 12th
they got six foot four okay you have to
wait on what the wall the other wait
right
in 196 right on the nose oh here's one
that says under review I saw one look at
this one this one says went to USC I did
well how long I didn't go I didn't
finish but oh yeah you went to school
for what how long did you go to USC for
I went for a few years because I started
at West LA college and then I went to
[Music]
really go go what does that mean you see
that that's a good picture me no and
that's what you're worth a hundred grand
that's more realistic he's a
multi-millionaire the walls four years
you talking about I still got I got all
mine I'm dying up here money in a piggy
bank that's all that's left of that six
now made me give it back
how on a lighter note to how did you
guys finish all the episodes of the the
deke show yeah of Dave yeah there were
they're done I mean who knows if we'll
ever be able to do it again depending on
if they wanted to do it again depend on
us right yeah I get all this I can't
imagine that they're gonna I can't
imagine it that's gonna let that I see
them I can see all the networks being
like okay we're gonna start from scratch
we canceling everything and starting
over you know what I mean yeah I don't
know man I like I think the show is
doing really well for FX and for Hulu
but numbers wise or it's really good but
I don't which is funny because you know
me we've talked about I don't know
anything about that like somebody has to
send it to me for me to go oh okay I
didn't I don't know any better
remember I was the one I was all over
that when we were on I was group texting
everybody like here's this week it never
never for me I never cared about like
checking in or cause anxiety I was like
well I don't know let it be but yeah
somebody sent me and they were like it's
doing really well so I hope they want to
like continue it or some [ __ ] I don't do
it's like everything
seem so up into year open the air yeah
the only thing that I really want
honestly is to get back on the [ __ ]
road and do shows I mean I sold Ozzy's
make in the Comedy Store how about that
just get back there I work out yeah I'd
be nice to go work out at the store and
[ __ ] me just to go see some people do a
set hangout I mean dude the store better
feel the biggest [ __ ] party on earth
when we come back I know it should but
it should be like like like a whole week
like seven three nights of comedy for
fans to just come and go tickets are
free just first-come first just to
celebrate this like getting this [ __ ] I
think it's gonna take a minute before
even when they go let's say even if they
got a vaccine or if they or if they had
more ability to like take care of people
because that's what we need to work on
first and then I still don't think
people are gonna rush back you know in
intro yeah you know I don't know I do
die you never know people people people
are still living normal now there's
parts of the country where people are
like whatever
I mean legit there's people right now
that aren't that don't have this
quarantine [ __ ] that stay in place or
safer at home and all these stuff that
every state is some of the states are
doing like there's plenty of places
where they're like it's fine don't worry
theatres still though the the last week
was the first time ever that the box
office was zero well that's that's a
federal ordinance right they can't they
legally can't be open all right so what
I'm saying there's some places where
it's like yes they're trying to act
normal but they still like just a lot of
things that they can't do still right so
but they're still states in the US that
don't have the regulation so they can
still go to restaurants they can still
go to like regular stores you know I
mean like there's still plenty of places
that don't have a because it's not
federal on on that level yet like it
hasn't gotten to where it's a federal
law did you see the video I talked about
the other day you see the video the
dudes in India the cops in India are
just beating the [ __ ] out of people if
they are outside cuz they they're on
lockdown don't know what city was they
believe them yeah I beat them with like
bamboo sticks google it bro you'll see
they're beating the [ __ ] out of them
you're not allowed to get street in some
city you know and and so if they catch
you out you know India's they good they
got their own rules they're beating the
[ __ ] out of these people there was no
like I'm gonna call the cops on the cops
[ __ ] you know you know yeah do they
got the videos got to be there on
YouTube it's I mean I'm trying to find
it myself because we looked at it the
other day it's wild how they're just
hitting with bamboo like one dude gets
hit in the face oh this here's one right
yeah oh this is three months ago though
in footage of Indian police beating up
students this is actually I can thing if
you know if you look at India beating up
people they beat up people a lot it
seems look up Indian police beat people
during quarantine or something that
there's got to be like a police feed
somebody found it yesterday when I was
talking to someone about it okay let's
see what we can find here yeah but you
know turns out wow here it is right here
[Laughter]
you know why the [ __ ] inside this [ __ ]
is crazy dude look at these please act
like they safe
look at that right you think that no
[ __ ] mask is doing a job and here's
another thing too so they're hitting
people with a stick that they think has
Corona and spreading it and then hitting
other people with that same stick these
are spread in Corona with everywhere
every a split but they making people do
push-ups [ __ ]
so they squats man they gotta get
tighter glutes though they got to get
those thighs up make them push-ups and
sit-ups to make a fork out god exercise
the corona out of your body what's
happening right now the world is [ __ ]
upside down my you know I don't know man
here give me a give me a high-five Ben
let's touch through the screen another
way always talk about online virus but
anyways look man I really appreciate you
taking the call and coming on
let's stay in touch you know you're very
precious friend to me even though you
guys talk to my [ __ ] about me on your
podcast but honestly we don't know we
don't ever talk when we called you the
other day that'll be on that was so
funny man you're so you're so goddamn
funny we I just think we want to keep
calling all the time just Skype we
should just you know get it set up we're
getting we're getting it set up
I'm just skyping with you guys we just
do it where we are we want to set up
video for real because we rather new
video chats with you the problem is we
can only video chats at people we know
because you know the transference of
information and all that [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah you know what I mean like keep it
on this secure network anyway much love
to hang your wife to men
thank you brother you're the best I'll
talk to you soon yeah man talk to you
soon thanks for taking the call dude all
right boy to you soon
all right guys that was Andrew Santino
my good buddy and you know he's doing
well and I hope you guys are doing well
out there and thank you for watching
Skype food with Griffin and we'll talk
soon
you